SCP-035 Vs Dr. Bright.
The timeless battle of an anomalous, body-stealing
medallion vs an anomalous, body-stealing mask.
But who would win the day?
Let’s find out.
Dr. Bright is functionally immortal thanks
to the SCP-963 amulet, which is also an incredibly
effective weapon against non-anomalous human
targets - inducing instant brain death upon
contact.
However, his human hosts are often just as
vulnerable as normal humans.
SCP-035 is also functionally immortal.
It has frightening psychological effects over
its victims, and secretes caustic, black liquid,
however, this comes at the major cost of slowly
rotting its own host.
Personally, we’d give this one to Dr. Bright.
He may not be eldritch, but his tactical knowledge
and experience in dealing with anomalies - as
well as the fact his medallion won’t ruin
the physical integrity of his hosts - gives
him an advantage over this nasty mask.